one night a year there will be you know
this will be the center of something I
mean the tenth of December this thing
will glow and and become a public
destination but I think that in terms of
the sustainability and the robustness of
the institution is something for 365
days a year then we have to think about
the diverse visitors that will come so
some people will come very informally
local people will come very informally
so the building tries to offer something
at the public level so the ground floor
will be an exhibition space it will be
free entry and it will be changing and
it will be a place to come and have a
coffee and it will be a place where you
can see what the noble is doing so it's
very important that this is very
transparent with three entrances that
coming in and this is such a very open
and transparent place which I think will
help relate the building to its locality
to to the people of stock now to sort of
the informal visitor you know the
building accommodates and encourages the
sort of parallel uses things going on at
the same time and different types of
audiences from the tourists to the local
to the school group to the scientific
discussions that will happen here I mean
I think this is a very important aspect
of Nobel that once this extraordinary
auditorium will exist it has to be used
for the rest of the year and this is now
very central to the to the program of
the place so that will be a continuous
programme of events of conference of
scientific conference of debate the
forum so this will be a place where
people come together
and the building has to respond to this
idea of people coming together and not
just one type of person coming at one
one moment but different people coming
at the same time actually it's a sort of
globally public building located in
Stockholm built on on the credibility
that has been made by Nobel over this
over the last century in that sense it's
an extraordinary virtual and real
project